a vaccine for corona virus could be at
least a year away but the government
seems to be trying to engineer the same
effect with something called herd
immunity the expectation is that enough
people will become infected with the
virus that they develop immunity this
would stop it spreading widely and
protect the vulnerable here's an example
we know that each person who catches the
virus is likely to pass it to between
two point four and three others but if
enough people develop immunity then
transmission is reduced considerably
because there are fewer susceptible
people but how many is enough depends on
how contagious the disease is as this
chart shows measles is very infectious
one person can pass it on to twelve
others and so for herd immunity to work
around 90% need to be immune but
coronavirus reproduces at a fast slower
rate so successful containment requires
just 60% of people to have been infected
and develop resistance now taking the UK
as a whole that's around 40 million
people catching kovat 19 the available
evidence suggests 32 million or 80% of
them would have mild symptoms but that
means around 8 million we could have
severe or critical symptoms and would
need treatment in hospital the
government expects 50% of those severe
cases to be in hospital during the peak
of the outbreak which is expected to
last around 3 weeks and that would put
considerable strain on the NHS but of
course that assumes you haven't isolated
the most vulnerable people and that
could be crucial each death is a death
too much and each person who has to be
admitted in intensive care
occupies a bed that may be essential to
save lives for someone who has a stroke
or or heart failure or what have you so
I don't think we can let nature go you
know it's game scientists also have no
idea how long it would take for 60% of
the population to become infected that
number simply hasn't been reached in any
other country